I respect the speaker's commitment to
take Social Security and Medicare off
the table for the debt ceiling
negotiations
we've got to put them on the table in
the long term and right now President
Biden's policy is insolvency remember
what happened at the State of the Union
when Joe Biden merely suggested some
Republicans
are open to cutting some Republicans
want Medicare and Social Security Sunset
I'm not
saying no
back my office
I'll give you a copy I'll give you a
copy of the proposal and there was you
saw Marjorie Trader green standing and
screaming so they say for weeks and
weeks no we would never ever ever ever
ever do that and then here goes Mike
Pence and he's like oh yeah it should
absolutely be on the table we have way
too much debt